prices are going up in Iraqi stores
since mid-november the dinar has
declined against US dollar losing about
10 percent of its value
aburonet says he doubly checks the price
tags every time he comes to the
supermarket
Chopin is blame it on the dollar
exchange rate because most of the
products are imported in this case the
government should pay our salaries in
dollars
the official exchange rate is fixed at
1470 Dinars per dollar
but recently it's been trading as high
as 1 600. since November the US has
tightened the rules on International
transfers to prevent money laundering
its reduced cash flows to Iraqi banks by
about 80 percent
it's clear the U.S federal reserve is
scrutinizing foreign transfers from Iraq
especially to those countries unfriendly
with the us such as Iran Lebanon Syria
and Yemen consequently Iraq's daily wire
transfers from the U.S have been cut
from 240 million dollars to only 22
million dollars on a day
the government has launched a campaign
to combat illegal currency trading and
promised to hold further discussions
with Washington to stabilize the
exchange rate
this is one aspect of an economic
challenge that requires a brave response
and practical solutions to end the wrong
Financial policies inherited by the
current government
in the meantime the Prime Minister has
extended credit to small businesses by
half a billion dollars despite
government promises to contain the
depreciation many Iraqis are worried
about an increase in prices ahead of the
holy month of Ramadan
especially in Imports such as gas and
weeds
a number of currency exchanges have
stopped trading until there is more
certainty about raids some Iraqis blame
the central bank for the shortage of
dollars
others accuse the United States of
weaponizing the dollar either way it's
the Iraqi people who built the brunt of
the changes